elodie 34 ans est l'une des 1300
étudiants de l'institut supérieur de
management
après une dizaine d'années en tant que
directrice de magasin la jeune femme a
décidé de se tourner vers une carrière
de drh sans expérience dans le domaine
sa seule solution était de reprendre ses
études en alternance et la jeune
étudiante ne regrette pas son choix très
très positif je savais que la charge de
travail serait assez intense donc
j'étais préparée psychologiquement voilà
en plus du feutre pour les études après
10 en mai
mais bon ça massa m'a pas fait peur je
pense que quand on est motivé qu'on a un
projet vraiment est on fait abstraction
de des contraintes et puis et puis voilà
avec un taux de chômage de 23 4% chez
les jeunes de 15 à 24 ans
l'apprentissage est un axe primordial de
la politique du gouvernement de françois
hollande c'est aussi une demande des
entreprises qui souhaitent que les
étudiants et déjà une expérience
professionnelle à la sortie de leur
cursus
une demande à laquelle répond l'iace m
depuis maintenant six ans certains nos
étudiants peuvent faire trois années
d'expérience professionnelle
donc ce qu'il y avait effectivement
particulièrement ensuite bien placé pour
pouvoir être recrutés et pour les
entreprises
ça permet justement de former des jeunes
et ensuite c'est une genre de
pré-embauche parce qu'ensuite ils
peuvent garder ce qui
identifie comme étant suffisamment bon
suffisamment adapté à ce dont ils ont
besoin et les entreprises sur le plutôt
satisfaites sur les 500 entreprises
partenaires de l'institut supérieur de
management
plusieurs étudiants en alternance sont
recrutés directement à la sortie de
leurs études